you said that you went to where'd you go
did you go to the West Bank our plan was
really to shoot between Haifa Tel Aviv
and the West Bank when we were there we
weren't able to actually shoot in the
West Bank there was this
um really kind of just horrible thing
that happened this journalist Sharina
was killed you know and that happened
while you were there or just before you
went there on our locations oh Jesus so
it was kind of this thing too where you
know my mom was like
why are you gonna shoot there can't you
just shoot it somewhere else I'm like no
we have to go there like we I want to
work with the crews there whatever and
it'll be safe don't worry don't don't
believe that she said Vancouver yeah
shoot Vancouver for Tel Aviv that's how
much my favorite I didn't really
answering that many fur trees
in Israel that's incredible my parents
know that much about the industry
they're pitching Vancouver no it would
really be great they're like no no the
rates in Vancouver are great I was like
you gotta let my dad's you gotta lead
with the tax incentive all right go to
Vancouver go to Toronto be smart save
the person this reminds me of I was
watching
um
I went and saw a Top Gun with my son and
at the end they have that big you know
they go we go together with like we go
to war with a fictional country and you
it's kind of not clear where it is but
there's just a lot of fur trees and a
lot of snow and it looks really
beautiful and the lights came up
afterwards and I said why did we go to
war with New Hampshire yes
that's a funny idea someone who's like
you know we could go we probably should
go to Tel Aviv
I don't know we got such a good rate in
Vancouver
who's gonna really know
I'm just gonna really know don't think
New Mexico wasn't thrown out on a call
really Conan you know enough to know New
Mexico
absolutely yeah absolutely that's not on
the call by the way no one talks about
how woke the new Top Gun is they really
don't mention another country it's kind
of nice you don't know you don't know
who it is you'd like to say it's woke
you could also say that they wanted to
make sure that it did well in every
Market internationally which is I
suspect what was really going on there
you know I call that financially woke
that's beautiful hey let's start that
movement the financially woke movement
just like no no well that's very
financially that was very offensive well
but financially very woke actually very
well yeah I did I did walk out of that
going wow I didn't hear Arabic I didn't
know what country was pretty impressive
look at that they did it way to go Tom I
was excited I was in there I was like
whoa it was so generic as a country and
I thought place looks beautiful I don't
know where they are but
exist Turks and Caicos yeah exactly I
also love that in the movie
um they had far superior fighter planes
than the United States and I'm like
which country is this it's a country
I've never heard of that looks
suspiciously like Maine
and they have airplanes fighter jets
that are like three generations ahead of
ours wait a minute
don't we have the most expensive
military in the world who laid down on
the job and let Switzerland get all
these amazing planes so that kind of
blew my mind yeah no and that's why I
brought you in here by the way is yes I
wanted to sort of rope-a-dope you with
we'll talk about Rami and we'll talk
about you know your religion and the
struggle but I really want to talk about
Top Gun yeah and how I I wanted to know
about that country yeah I think we
walked out of that movie As Americans
with a lot of questions for our
government you know where are these
planes why don't we have them the other
thing that I love and I'm going to keep
going talking about Top Gun is that Tom
Cruise is the best
pilot ever he's dedicated his whole life
to um you know Maverick has dedicated
his whole life to
um serving his country he's absolutely
amazing everyone says hands down he's
the best any Superior officer like get
in here you [ __ ]
what was that stunt you pulled or you
did that really amazing thing and saved
everybody's life well sir I shut up shut
the [ __ ] up and I ran um
I ran into Jon Hamm somewhere as
everyone knows he's in addition to being
great actually he's a very funny guy but
I was like what was your problem with
Tom Cruise
all he's done is and he's like I know I
know
and all you do is and then it's like did
you see what Tom Cruise just did you see
what Maverick just did he just saved
America and that person was lost and he
rescued him and then he put a plane
together out of Legos and got everybody
out of there yeah get him in here you
piece of [ __ ] well because I think
you're forgetting the beginning of the
movie he blows up an expensive plane
right which goes against the movie's
principles of financial wokeness I think
that's that is you know the biggest
issue okay I feel you know like I mean
if you're kind of tracking the the
through line of what they care about the
guy's [ __ ] up I mean because it's not
about the country I mean it's it's about
the budget you're right you're right and
and so I see it now he's a budget he did
blow up that plan yeah get in here you
little [ __ ] you're ruining our budget if
you save more lives one more time
it's just that old Trope that's in
everybody cop movie where you have to
get chewed out even though you've
clearly done an amazing job oh you're
handsome you're skilled somehow you're
the underdog yeah I don't know how
literally just gorgeous yeah like just
better skin than my sister I know and I
don't know I root for that guy because I
think we are about the same age and I'm
just
when I'm just you know he like takes his
shirt off in that movie and I somehow
felt that I had gotten in shape yeah
just because and I just was like see I
am a movie star my wife's like what are
you talking about well we're the same
age right but he's got all these genetic
gifts which you do not have and he works
out like crazy and you do not and I was
like
I think you should write like a thing
piece you know it's just like Tom Cruise
got jacked for my whole generation he
did I think he did it for all of you
yeah thank you beautiful right I think
you're shocked when you saw me in person
and how old I look uh and I think you
look great and I thought you were very
tall that's really what struck me
because when we were hugging it was just
long hug and I was just firmly mid in
the middle of your chest I I held you
amazing I held you for a while it
cradled you it's a really nice cradle
yeah your feet did not touch the ground
I lifted you I held you for a while I
put you in a Baby Bjorn remember that
and we walked around
around the Cirrus XM office and everyone
was like wow we don't know what this is
but if we don't know what it is but it
feels Progressive it feels very
Progressive yeah it feels like the
future
I I felt that I was like wow maybe maybe
things can change